and today's mariner starter a familiar
face three good years with the angels
probably the best set segment of his
long journeyman career it's the veteran
southpaw hector santiago you know the
number different type of fastball is
89.93 although a good change up slider
an occasional curveball my go-to is for
the angels at success against their
former teammate look for that fastball
upper third he'll try to throw a
four-seamer upstairs and be able to jump
on back in 2015 with the angels give up
29 home runs and barrel up the mistake
change up when he chased it out of the
zone that's when you're running the
problems a 313 batting average this year
versus his changeout got the old school
sterips working hector santiago today
for seattle
throwback sunday afternoon uniforms
fletch takes an elevated pitch and sends
it into left bowers is drifting in the
corner and he makes the catch clutch
denied the 24-game hit streak in his
first chance today here's otani hitless
yesterday and shohei on the first pitch
a rocket into right field that's going
to rattle around and ohtani's eyeing up
second base
and the angels have a one-out double to
start the ball game
ready for that one he also has a home
run against santiago this season shohei
picking up his 19th double little drop
down fastball
and shohei jumps on it hector quick
worker 01 pitch swung on and hit to left
field right at bowers he's there makes
the cap high catch and that'll do it the
double by oh tommy harmless
angels nothing across meredith coming to
bed jose suarez on the mound 10 games so
far very solid era 2.37
era with a whip 1.22
up the middle and this squeaks into
center field for a base hit off the bat
of jp crawford speaking of that here is
mitch haniger jp almost taunting over
first base here's a swing and a driving
right field sinking drive in front of
the right field of ward jp to second
he'll hold there and the mariners
building good first inning here
base hit mitch haniger fastball trying
to go in and doesn't quite get in there
and mitch able to take an inside out
approach first two hitters are on base
now for the first baseman ty france
who's gone one for four in each of the
first two games of the series here's the
one-two pitch from suarez here comes
pitch swing on sent to
deep center field this will be a run for
the mariners jp tags lagaris makes the
catch eases the ball back into the
infield to fletcher jp scores hanegar
tags goes to third mariners have a run
on the board it's one nothing seattle
and it is a change-up and he leaves it
in the middle of the plate almost middle
in and ty france knows exactly what to
do with that runner's at second and
third nobody out he's looking for a ball
he can get to the outfield in the air
this is popped up on the infield
[Applause]
fletcher at second base
two gone
so haniger has to hold at third base
that's the second out and jake fraley
will be in the next batter and the 2-2
and that is a called third strike he got
him looking a good fastball
and that will end the inning so the
first strikeout today for suarez seattle
gets a run though
in the inning they had a pair of hits a
lever runner at third we've completed
one inning that'll bring up david
fletcher his second opportunity this
afternoon to cash in and extend the
hitting streak to 24 only two longer in
franchise history
first pitch to fletch here is sent out
to deep left field bowers looking up and
it's gone streaks alive another homer
for fletch
boy fletch loving that coffee up there
in seattle there's a lot of coffee shops
and flesh with the energy two well hit
baseball this one gets out for fletch 24
games in a row
second home run
of the series
the change up and he covers it out left
center for fletch
just short through the baseball bauer's
going back looks up and say you know
what that's a tie ball game fletch lives
tying it up one to one here's otani he
doubled last time 107 off the bat here
comes the one two
swinging in a miss he got him
went upstairs with the fastball blew up
by him at 93 down goes ohtani and
santiago has given the mariners three
quality innings just one run allowed one
out one on fourth inning one one ball
game bill gaslin hard hit ground ball to
third baseman dylan moore his first time
up
payoff to goslin
he swings right through it
elevated slider round number two
typically you see that slider down in
the zone this one is up in the zone
right at the top gosling sees it eyes
light up but it's in that zone that's
tough to get on top of and swings
through it let's bring up the veteran
curt suzuki you know hard grounder
through the legs of starter hector
santiago but right behind home plate
with shed long the blue sky is just
spectacular today folks the one two
pitch from chigwa
got it
a delayed call by junior valentine the
home plate umpire but that's a called
strike three angels are done in the
fourth we go bottom four two balls and
two strikes
went back to the changeup and gets a fly
ball
walsh makes the play
that was willie may's style
that's a play we've seen walsh practice
a lot
in the uh weeks since the series and the
season
got underway and he
did a good job with that one running
over the shoulder grab in foul territory
a good pitch from suarez a change up
down her way second and third for fletch
with one away great opportunity here for
the angels 1-1
that's whacked into right field a base
hit for fletch that should score him
both ward across the plate
legarres scores and david fletcher
cashes in again i'm telling you matt he
needs a license plate with the i heart
risp he loves runners in scoring
position look at the location of this
pitch up about shoulder height the short
with the baseball he homers the left
center two rbi single with the one-two
pitch two out
the pitch swung on a miss struck him out
nicely done by mise to get the two big
guys in the order two-run single david
fletcher and angels now have a 3-1 lead
here at t-mobile park solo home run in
the third two rbi single in the fifth he
has provided all the runs here's the
next one on fletcher and he hits a low
liner that drops in for a base hit that
will score the runner legarres from
second and david fletcher has a
three-hit day he's had seven hits this
weekend
against seattle pitching and the angels
add on it's 4-1 and extended his hit
streak to 24 games first pitch swinging
david fletcher this ball up the middle
backhanded by watson and david fletcher
is going to get another hit an infield
hit right back up the middle here's
jared walsh now he is hitless today over
three has drawn a walk here's the next
delivery and walsh swings and lines one
into right that's going to drop in for a
base hit the angels are going to score a
run on that one as coming in is fletcher
from second
and that's an rbi base hit for jared
walsh and the lead gets bigger it's now
5-1 angels spaces are loaded with nobody
out
gosselin swings and sends a fly ball
down to center field that should tag and
score ohtani
six to one angels
and there's one that's chased and missed
the ball gets away from the catcher
raleigh and breaking in from third base
and coming in and scoring will be jared
walsh
here's the pitch and swinging at that
one and popping it up on the right side
of the infield
on the
dirt is david fletcher to make the catch
on that one moore is retired and so are
the mariners as the angels come away
with the victory this afternoon an
impressive win for the angels